Victoria Saha looks into what one
private school in the valley is doing to
keep their students safe
with the nation dealing with yet another
school shooting Faith Lutheran is
continuously wondering what more they
can do to keep their students safe and
is it enough they are terrifying images
coming out of Nashville and an
unfortunate reminder of how frequent
school shootings are a day does not go
by on this job that this does not cross
my mind Steve Buck Faith Lutheran CEO
says he won't compromise on safety I
have a responsibility to protect these
kids there are armed guards around
campus while they will not share how
many we can say it's costly and if we
save one life there's no amount of money
we wouldn't pay to do that they would
put themselves between kids and bad guys
very quickly director of security Pat
Sullivan says all staff have a cell
phone app called crisis go alerting them
when there is a drill or real scenario
we can communicate back and forth with
uh with each other to say that the bad
guy is you know in the North part of the
the campus so if you're in the South
part of the campus that gives you an
opportunity to evacuate the school also
invested in magnetic door stops so when
you do need to close the door it will
shut and lock easily the the pull Downs
cover up the windows that allows you to
get to your hiding spot inside the
classrooms and as the Nashville shooter
was able to shoot through locked doors
Faith Lutheran is also looking at buying
bulletproof doors Victoria Saha 8 News
Now
now Faith Lutheran also tells Victoria
they have National Consultants come out
every year to help increase security
measures as for those armed guards they
are former military and the school plans
to add even more